as nevada lawmakers continue to try and
secure more vaccine medical experts say
it is important to dice to disperse the
allocation we do have
joe muller is live outside the las vegas
convention center a site
that will be used as a vaccination
center joe
well christian over the past few weeks
we've learned of more and more locations
administering the vaccine now coming up
next week the convention center will be
administering the second dose for some
and another clinic is planned now this
is something medical experts say
is good that is happening nevada has
been
very low on the vaccine allocation as
nevada struggles to get vaccines dr
johann bester of unlv
says it is important to spread out the
vaccines that we do get
as we get more and more vaccine we
should really be rolling it out having
vaccine outreach vaccine clinics friday
a prototype clinic was held at jerome
middle school for those 70 and older
it was held on the east side of las
vegas strategically because that
is one of the hardest hit areas of the
state it's a work in progress but we
really are trying to duplicate what we
did with the testing
the county commissioner tick sigerblum
says this is the first of many they want
to have
in the past the estantos manos campaign
worked on kobe 19
testing outreach within the hispanic
community the hispanic community still
makes up 30 percent of the cases
cigareblum says outreach is key part of
this process is going to be to start
reaching out there
into the community have people
vaccinated have them go back to their
homes to their neighborhoods and say i
did it there's no problem
boulder city is starting to vaccinate
those 65 and older
tuesday the las vegas convention center
will start offering second doses
another pop-up clinic will happen
february 3rd through the 5th at the
doolittle senior center
dr bester says the more places the
better the more we roll out the vaccine
the more we can see how safe it is
i mean over 20 million doses has now
been administered in the u.s
now back out here live you only you will
only be coming here to the convention
center if you received your first dose
from one of the health district sites we
have much more information on all the
vaccine
locations up on our website that's
eightnewsnow.com reporting live at the
convention center this evening joe mohl
8 news now